welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and when Marvel Studios unveiled
their Multiverse Saga timeline to me the
cruelest part of it was the phase six
lineup with eight empty titles for 2024
and 2025 in the slots between Fantastic
Four Avengers the King Dynasty and
Avengers Secret Wars clearly this was by
Design to have us looking forward to d23
when presumably these titles will be
revealed and the god Emperor Mouse will
be pleased that the good cheese was safe
for him since Marvel Studios initially
didn't intend to do a Comic-Con panel at
all we all have to assume that studio is
saving the goods for d23 like the cast
and director of Fantastic Four hinted
the exact lineups of Kang Dynasty and
Secret Wars as well as the casts of
other titles like Thunderbolts Captain
America New World Order Daredevil born
again and of course our beloved mutants
my buds on the break room began to try
to fill in the phase six slate but as
someone with my own ear to the ground
with additional insights in how this
business really operates I shall present
my phase six lineup so when we are
seeking to fill in these eight slots
there are a number of currently unplaced
titles a mutants title of perhaps many
mutants titles Deadpool 3 armor Wars
Young Avengers Wonder Man and Okoye
series a sequel to Shang Chi a Sheng Chi
spin-off series and then a possible Nova
title Loki season 3 Miss Marvel season 2
of rumored eternals 2 a rumored Scarlet
Witch solo film and a possible midnight
Sons team up because you know we gotta
get Mephisto in there somewhere now we
also learned at Comic-Con about animated
titles but they probably won't factor
into these eight open spots like what if
season 2 and X-Men 97 are both confirmed
for 2023 but we're not on the phase 5
board Spider-Man freshman year and
Marvel zombies are coming in 2024 but
are not one of these Eight titles for
phase six right away we should dispel
the notion that one of those eight phase
six slots belongs to a fourth Spider-Man
film that's not to say another MCU
Marvel Sony Spider-Man film cannot come
out during this period it's just that
Marvel Studios never at this stage
introduces a Spider-Man title as part of
their slate that tends to come later
after Disney and Sony hammer out the
details indeed as was the case when
feige announced Civil War in Infinity
War Parts 1 and 2 in October 2014
announcing these huge crossover events
years and the future is partly a
negotiating tool to entice Sony into
sharing their Spider-Man IP so that
Peter Parker or in this case Miles
Morales gets to be part of this historic
event actually don't be surprised if we
learn about fourth Spider-Man title to
come out during phase five perhaps
December 2023. since contractually to
keep Spider-Man It is believed that Sony
must release a new live-action
Spider-Man title every two years which
is why despite pandemic delays
Spider-Man no way home still came out in
the calendar year of 2021 which even
forced Marvel Studios to do costly
reshoots for Multiverse of Madness to
maintain continuity holiday 2023 at this
moment is open aside from blade in early
November 2023 really that sounded like
more of a Halloween movie meanwhile
Disney's Avatar sequels will be coming
out in 2022 2024 2026 and 2028 and no
Star Wars films are scheduled yet for
the holiday seasons so December 2023 is
really the perfect time for another MCU
Spider-Man film okay so getting back to
phase six in 2024 and 2025 two Avengers
movies in one year is insane don't be be
surprised if Secret Wars gets pushed to
2026 which would open up that fall 2025
tent pole spot there is a lot of
discussion that a mutants film will be
announced at d23 I think it is very
likely but I also think it's likelier
that only one other theatrical release
film will come out in the year 2025 and
I think the likeliest option is Deadpool
3. that movie is already well underway
so I'm gonna place that in the winter
2025 slot potentially a February release
like quantumania's February release in
2023 and the first Deadpool's release on
Valentine's Day weekend in 2016. this
will enable Deadpool to appear both in
King Dynasty and Secret Wars later in
the year there is some unconfirmed
speculation out there that you may have
heard that Marvel Studios might not be
able to reboot and recast mutants in the
MCU until after 2025 after reportedly
some of the fox actors contracts expire
Ryan Reynolds and Patrick Stewart would
have been excluded from this since
they're the same actors I just don't
know if that's true because actors are
not really known to have Legacy Clauses
like that in their contracts that have
stand so far into the future without new
movies being made in between like even
before the Disney acquisition Fox
probably would not have signed contracts
like that with their cast so ignoring
all that I really do think the second
summer 2025 slide could be a mutant
related title but I also think it's
possible that it will not be called the
mutants really think about it the
smarter move for Marvel Studios would be
to introduce mutants one mutant at a
time a period of mutants at a time or
groups of mutants at a time like a
wolverine solo series a cyclops solo
series a storm solo series The Runaways
Xavier Academy Magneto brotherhood like
why do one mutants title when you could
do infinite at ones that cross over with
each other and give you a future phase 7
team up event to look forward to
everybody has a smell it comes with the
territory of Being Human just like
having a face and having a voice and
having an evil twin with frustratingly
awesome hair it's something that's
absolutely true for all of us the nice
thing about your smell is that you can
choose it with said bird said bird is
reimagining everything about how people
discover a shop for purchase and even
experience fragrances every month you
get to choose the designer fragrances
that you want to receive there are
perfumes colognes and a ton of unisex
options you get a 30-day supply of each
fragrance so you can try them out before
committing to an expensive full-size
bottle send a sample worth hundreds of
dollars that will make you smell better
than your evil twin with a forcingly
awesome hair not sure what kind of
fragrances are for you or you can take a
simple quiz on scentbird they'll help
you find the fragrance you'll love
scentbird carries luxury Brands like
Prada Gucci Versace and Niche Brands
like Skylar heretic and Confessions of a
rebel this month my box included
Skyler's Salt Air our quiz it non-bun
Mercedes he's been signed and Maison
sibleyte Amber gays and this Amber gays
oh baby hey I love it it's got Jasmine
Violet Sandalwood they call it the
ultimate Love Potion with an exotic
complex floral Aroma rich and classy two
things that I wasn't before I tried on
this perfume but now now
if you want to level up your scent game
in order to frustrate your evil twin for
once make sure to use our coupon code
for 55 off at scentbird it's just a
little over seven dollars reverse month
available in the USA and in Canada now
another possible theatrical release film
in the year of 2025 would be shengchi II
however with Destin Daniel [ __ ]
recently announced a direct Avengers the
King Dynasty and remember this guy is
also directing the Wonder Man series I
doubt he would have time to focus on all
of these within the same year so either
he would have to take a step back from
shenzhitu or shungshi 2 would be pushed
into phase seven okay so let's jump back
to the start of phase six this first
fall 2024 slot is Gonna Come shortly
after Thunderbolts and this I think
could be where armor Wars is going I
think the other fall 2024 slot would go
to a title like midnight Sons something
blade could set up a year earlier we
just got a poster showing Johnny Blaze
in footage for She-Hulk I just wouldn't
be surprised if a midnight Sun's title
gets announced for phase six at d23 now
I doubt Marvel Studios has made
decisions yet about a second season a
Miss Marvel or a third season of Loki so
let's just leave those off the board for
now but for winter 2024 we're talking
December Christmas season so for that I
think we need a Christmas special or
some kind of holiday binge she's the way
Hawkeye was and depending on Destin
Daniel cretin's schedule wonder man
could fit really well there Wonder Man
Simon Williams is a stunt actor working
in Hollywood in the MCU has a history of
Shane black style Los Angeles Christmas
action comedies with Iron Man 3. so if
we assume Wonder Man being a
light-hearted story I don't know I could
just see that working really well as a
Christmas title but then on the other
side of Deadpool for that first spring
2025 spot to set up Xiang Chi as an
Avengers leader in the [ __ ] directed
Kang Dynasty if we don't see shangchi in
2025 the song Chi spin-off series a 10
Ring series does make a lot of sense
there remember we did see some concept
art of Deadpool fighting in a golden
dagger cage fight those are the kind of
matchups that could come true in this 10
Ring series which would work amazingly
as an MCU fighting tournament to get us
all in the mood for Secret Wars at the
end of the year that second spring 2025
spot I think it worked well for another
good Prelude to the Kang Dynasty Young
Avengers the seeds have been planted the
MCU would be wise to establish iron
lad's backstory on the eve of Kang's
rise so if we assume one of the summer
22 25 slots is a mutant related title
that would lead that other early summer
2025 slot open for a couple different
options maybe the Okoye series there's
speculation for a Nova title maybe a
Scarlet Witch solo title but I really
think this would just be another great
opportunity for a different mutant
related title on Disney plus between
Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars you got two
opportunities there for Marvel on that
platform to introduce their new X-Men in
the summer of 2025. so yeah maybe get
one of these as a cyclops or a storm
solo title with another one perhaps
centered around Xavier there you go I
think that's a pretty solid base6 lineup
that when you pair with all the titles
in base five does offer a wide range of
Heroes to bring back for Secret Wars at
the end of the Multiverse Saga and let's
not forget that understanding of Sony's
Spider-Man contract is Drew a new title
every two years we would be looking at a
fifth MCU Spider-Man title in December
of 2025 and I can't even begin to
imagine that let me know your thoughts
on this lineup and what title is your
most excited for and thanks again to
scentbird for sponsoring this episode
and be sure to check out all the links
below follow me on Instagram and Twitter
at gave us follow new Rockstar subscribe
to new Rockstar some more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
um